hey youtubers is Charlie so a lot of you
are asking me to do video about
Prometheus who is he so I'm gonna
explain that but also how the show is
spinning into a green arrow rebirth arc
for next season there's a new round of
the flash ring giveaway going on right
now all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video be sure to click that Bell to
enable alerts so you don't miss anything
during the break so there's still a
whole bunch of questions about
Prometheus just because that you know
they have it like rip the mask off and
been like aha
it's you the / you know the person we've
been wondering about this entire season
so an arrow fashion I actually think
they've already revealed who it is in
the back half of the season will be more
about their psychology in the way that
say like Deathstroke Slade was unmasked
as the villain during the season 2
mid-season finale like season 2 episode
9 and then the back half of the season
was diving deeper into his psychosis
like why is he doing this like how deep
has he sunk how crazy has he gotten in
what is it that he's going to do to team
arrow so the great thing I think they
did in episode 9 is give you pretty much
all the information you need to identify
who this person is but the reason I
think there's still a lot of questions
people like is it Tommy is that you know
somebody else that we've seen before is
because like none of the characters came
out and said it's this person and then
you know like when they did the Slade
reveal show like a zoom in on their face
so because they didn't do that I think
there's still a lot of questions so they
actually gave you all the evidence you
needed as team arrow is sort of like
jumping through the hoops trying to find
out who it is because before episode 9
they'd already found out that it was
somebody who knew about the list we knew
that Artemis had given him all this
extra information about team arrow but
he already knew that Oliver was the
Green Arrow so a lot of that plays into
stuff that we'll find out about in the
back half of the season how long has he
known that Oliver was the green arrow at
what point did he decide to start
training to defeat Oliver but we know
one that he was also trained by the same
person that Oliver was trained by just
because he has the same moves that
person is Talia al Ghul like in the
preview for episode 10 he's talking to
Diggle here in prison he says there's a
woman he's trying to track down
what to do a train the two of you well
she doesn't stay in one spot for very
long I'm working on fighting her she
moves around a lot so she's really hard
to find but he references his time back
in Russia so naturally because the
flashbacks are in Russia we'll see that
play out over the course of the
flashbacks that will also probably see
her eventually in present day so Talia
al Ghul very important to the Prometheus
mystery and you do kind of wonder like
why would she train someone to defeat
someone else that she also trained so
she doesn't sound very loyal to Oliver
or anything like that
but that does kind of sound in keeping
with Talia's character we'll be talking
a lot about Talia in the back half of
the season but the next big thing is
they're jumping through Prometheus hoops
like learning things during episode 9 is
that Oliver finds a drug that reminds
him of Justin Claybourne way back in
season 1 so he's like ah it's got to be
Claybourne but I killed him so you know
what's the deal but they track him down
to claybournes old plant in fine
Prometheus has laid a trap for Oliver
and is just messing with his head so
they still think it's Claybourne at this
point then he sees his moves and is like
oh my god you know he must have trained
with Talia and they get some ashes off
of him and start to analyze it but
conveniently as they continue to pursue
this Justin Claybourne lead it takes the
rest of the episode to analyze those
ashes like the DNA and find out who it
is that prometheus has been carrying
around this whole time and then they
find that it's actually just in
claybournes ashes so Justin Claybourne
really is dead who is prometheus so
leading to the next big clue Billy goes
to Prometheus's office opens the safe
and finds a picture of a baby in all a
sudden just as he's able to send the
picture to felicity
Prometheus just shows up like a ghost
captures him and we know how the rest of
the episode plays out like dresses him
up to look like Prometheus so that
Oliver kills him just trying to turn the
rest of the group against Oliver like
Prometheus wants to destroy team arrow
but instead of just killing everyone
like he tells Artemis he wants Oliver to
suffer so he wants to destroy team arrow
in the most excruciatingly torturous way
possible both mentally and physically
and that's going to take the entire
back half of the season so really like
the other you know next big clue about
who prometheus is is when he reaches the
rooftop like before he kills Billy where
he flashes back to the moment that he
finally killed Claybourne you know
Claybourne is very unrepentant he's like
you know those people that were gonna
die they didn't matter anyway Oliver it
gives him the you failed this city takes
him down that's the end of it but then
it flashes back to present day and
Prometheus throws that in his face you
know did you bat an eyelash when you
killed him did you feel any remorse did
you feel bad about it you gotta tell me
again I failed this city
you infected the people on land valley
to turn a profit do you want to make the
city great again this is how with
business money you are sentencing
innocent families children to death
nobody cares about those people they're
a blight
I'm just thinning the herd so oh boy
did you hesitate at all when you killed
him or was he just another name you
crossed off your list
if you want revenge I'm right here this
is about so much more than revenge so
the only thing they don't do in the
episode is attach a name to the who like
they found out that this is Justin
claybournes illegitimate son but they
don't say this is his first and last
name that's still the mystery so we
already know who prometheus is the baby
photo recorder records related to
claymores divorce baby is claybournes
son you told when Claybourne didn't have
any kids not of the legitimate variety
but the divorce petition claybournes
ex-wife filed says otherwise there's no
record of the kid's name and the files
but due to the filing date he'd be about
30 today just old enough to put on a
hood and a mask old enough to want
revenge on the man who murdered his
father I think an arrow tradition to
twist itself about the identity of
Prometheus isn't that complicated it's
not so much about the who it's about the
what he's going to do to Oliver how
Oliver is gonna deal with that over the
back half of the season that's really
where it seems like most of the writers
energy is going you know bright filiz so
like the twist itself isn't that big of
a revelation like Oliver killed a bad
person but that bad person had a family
of his own now they feel justified in
seeking retribution against Oliver for
taking everything away from them so that
kind of goes back to Artemis and the
reason why she started to help
Prometheus because she felt like Oliver
was being dishonest and was actually
hurting the city more than he was
helping it even though that's kind of
bullcrap the producers did say a long
time ago that the show was built on
Oliver smih stakes like the way they
wrote the show Oliver tries to do
something as a hero tries to make his
city better but in doing so actually
causes a bunch of his own problems the
same way that Barry does you know most
big heroes cause a lot of their own
problems so even though we don't know
the actual name of Prometheus like you
know what his actual name is he is just
in claybournes illegitimate son it's
just you know there's just so much about
his character
that we don't know yet that they'll
reveal over the back half of the season
it's not so much who he is it's just in
explaining his character in what he's
been doing these last five years like
going around and collecting all of
Oliver's discarded arrows and melting
them down and reforging them that's like
a crazy hard task to do he's been
plotting this revenge for a long time
just in the same way that Deathstroke
was plotting his revenge against Oliver
for a long time so I know everybody's
really excited that they're kind of back
to basics season 1 season 2 style arrow
with the way they plot the episodes and
how things are working so in the way
that the Deathstroke arc played out over
the course of the back half of season 2
I think a lot of the Prometheus arc the
back half of the season will feel like
that so hopefully this explains a little
bit about Prometheus like the who is
kind of already been explained
he's just the stuff that we don't know a
whole lot about that they're gonna
continue to reveal is the why in the
what part of what he's going to be doing
to Oliver to continue his mission of
just completely destroying his psyche
the other big thing is that what does
this say about season 6 like you know
where is Oliver gonna get to by the end
of the season if he's able to defeat
prometheus well he oh he's going to like
reassert who he is like redefine what
the green arrow is what his mission is
it's gonna be like the green arrow
rebirth so to speak you know like they
have green arrow rebirth in the comics
so before you can have a rebirth you
sort of have to tear him down
so Prometheus is gonna be tearing Oliver
down so that season 6 can be a Green
Arrow rebirth and I think they'll
definitely make it to season 7 but
beyond that it just depends on whether
or not the actors want to keep making
the show you guys can let me know do you
feel like season six you know after this
Prometheus arc is gonna be something of
a Green Arrow rebirth for the TV show
they've got a version of a Black Canary
back even though it's black siren that's
gonna be a lot of fun to see how that
plays out and what her future on the
show is gonna be because in true fashion
like I think this will happen with
Prometheus - the biggest villains never
die they just go away for a little while
like unless you see a body they're not
dead so of course I think black sirens
gonna escape I think prometheus is gonna
escape - really what I want to see if
they make it to season 7 is to have like
a giant villain team-up Sinestro Corps
style where you do like the one-page
teaser where you have like desk
broke in every other big villain from
the arrowverse that's not a metahuman
teaming up to take down team arrow so I
feel like Prometheus has been a great
villain this season
hopefully they'll keep him around in the
future just in the way that they've kept
Deathstroke around to come back and play
with team arrow every once in a while
after his big arc has done this season
congratulations to this week's flash
ring giveaway winner king falcon please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details there is a new round that
started in this video I'll just remind
everyone when I post a new flash video
this weekend so what's gonna happen
tonight is I have new Star Wars Episode
8 teaser that I'm gonna post kylo Ren
was going on and on about his character
it is gonna be so awesome so kylo Ren
Star Wars posted tonight get hype where
you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for a new flash trailer and
you can click here to learn all about
the plot earth or Bagon rock they just
released the synopsis thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you in the next video